buenas noches idealmente una salida
diplomática en esta atención como lo
comentas que va escalando de nivel y es
que lo cierto es que los derechos
pesqueros son fundamentales para los dos
lados del canal de la mancha de hecho
fue uno de los iconos de la campaña a
favor del break sido así que pueden
dimensionar qué tan importante es para
este país
el ministro del break sin justamente
lord flows ha dicho que el reino unido
ha garantizado el 98 por ciento de las
aplicaciones de licencia que ha hecho la
unión europea y no se les puede hacer
extraño si en los próximos días estas
tensiones aumentan aún más de tono dado
que la próxima semana vence el plazo que
francia le dio el reino unido para
resolver toda esta situación el ministro
del 'break' si también ha dicho que
lamenta el lenguaje confrontacional que
francia está utilizando constantemente y
que éste no será un asunto fácil de
resolver luisa qué información maneja
acerca de las últimas repercusiones en
el largo político
el reino unido quiere sentar un
precedente quiere mostrar la diferencia
que este es un asunto de extrema
gravedad por ello ha convocado para
mañana a la embajadora francesa aquí en
londres para que les explique lo que ha
citado el gobierno británico lo que
considera decepcionantes y
desproporcionadas amenazas contra el
reino unido el ministro del brics y da
dicho hoy en una declaración que incluso
esas amenazas de las que ya nos dabas
cuenta son justamente en contra del
acuerdo break sit y del derecho
internacional y están planteando
justamente la dificultad que se está
exponiendo ahora entre francia y el
reino unido- una tensión que no
solamente ha tocado el break sit sino
también desde que eeuu australia el
reino unido anunciaron esta nueva
alianza de seguridad al curso